bienvenue sur les terres fragile des
bords de loire vous se développe depuis
plusieurs années huit ans à peu près le
pastoralisme avec pasto rizon d'héberger
s'installe qu'ici et les moutons
remplacent avantageusement les machines
pour entretenir les prairies ligérienne
des milieux ouverts qui auraient une
fâcheuse tendance à se refermer
cela permet de protéger la faune et la
flore de créer de l'activité de la
richesse
et quoi de plus bucolique qu'un troupeau
de moutons au bord de la loire
mais avant de rejoindre les moutons 1 km
d'ici nous retrouvons mylène la bergère
mal et qu'on est sûr météo font qu'on
peut plus du tout accès au chemin en
tout cas moi avec ce véhicule je peux
plus et heureusement qu'on a des amis
qui on est piqué par ainsi resté
embourbé son troupeau pâture
actuellement dans les shows de dominique
un éleveur bovin ses blondes d'aquitaine
sont allés table pour l'hiver les vaches
sont les laisser maintenant vous
n'auriez un bourbier comme bien à
l'entrée du prévenu alors que les
moutons c'est léger et donc ça n'abîme
pas le sol et en même temps ça mange
tout ce que la marche a pas mangé les
brebis sont pleines elles vivent dehors
toute l'année comme leur bergère on
apprend à vivre à leur rythme et on
s'impose pas
on s'impose pas la vie quotidienne
citadine loin de là quoi on est dans un
rythme beaucoup plus lent
la plupart des brebis sont issus du
troupeau de bernard girard le premier
berger itinérant on appelle cette
nouvelle espèce non sédentaires les
bregy les gardes systématiquement elles
nous arrivent très bien y aller en
extérieur avec alors vous en avez une là
un bon exemple c'est ça c'est une
biberon doit être à 18 entre 18 et 20
personnes qui sont passés par notre
collectif dont certains sont installés
c'est un peu le propos du collectif
c'est de permettre à des porteurs de
projets de tester leur capacité à
devenir berger mais c'est aussi de l'or
de les autoriser à ne pas le faire si
jamais ils voient que ça ne convient pas
alors alors il des premières fois
aujourd'hui past horizon c5 berger un
millier de brebis et plus de 2000
hectares d'espacés naturels sensibles
pâturer chaque année le seul problème
est financier
un berger doit se contenter en moyenne 2
500 euros par mois
il ya des années où c'était viable à
l'époque où nous avions la possibilité
de signer des contrats natura 2000
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas ça le sera
peut-être dans l'avenir mais aujourd'hui
ce n'est plus le cas donc économiquement
c'est très difficile par contre en terme
d'entretien des espaces et très
économique
on va dire pour les services de l'état
enfin pour la cause
nationale on va t'aider ce qui serait
souhaitable aujourd'hui c'est que ce
service rendu soit reconnu et que les
bergers itinérant qui travaillent sur
des espaces environnementaux soient
rémunérés à la hauteur du service qu'ils
rendent par solidarité paysanne
dominique près de ces prêts à l'éleveuse
itinérante le territoire y vit parce
qu'il ya il ya des humains entre
guillemets qui viennent sur le
territoire s'il ya pas d'humains il ya
plus de territoire il ya plus rien c'est
la forêt vierge depuis trois ans mylène
vit près de ces bêtes d'une prairie à
l'autre elle habite dans sa caravane au
printemps avec ses agneaux
elle ira jusqu'au bec d'allier pour
quelques mois en bord de loire